Welcome to 40 Days of Holiness. Remember, we're doing these 10 days, we are
collecting metaphors for holiness.
Metaphors are word pictures that teach us what holiness
is, that spark our imaginations about it and inspire us to
long for it. All right? So Jesus doesn't usually teach us in formulas
or checklists or bullet points. Usually, the scripture
gives a word picture to capture and
inspire our imagination and our longing.
So that's what this 10 days is about. All right?
So today's metaphor is that holiness is a further
cleaning, a further cleansing beyond salvation.
We're in several different verses today, but first of all, in John 17,
which is Jesus' high priestly prayer for his disciples.
Now, at this time, they're Christians, but in verse 19, he
says they need to be truly sanctified.
Now, I want you to notice as we're looking through, the things that
are already true about the disciples.
So follow with me down through John 17.
It says they're given to Jesus in verse number six.
They're given by God the Father, verse six. They have obeyed God's word.
In verse eight, it says they accepted Jesus's word.
It says they believed Jesus is from God, and they belong to God the
Father and to Jesus, verses nine and ten.
Verse 10 says they've glorified God.
Verse 14 and 16 says they are not part of the world.
It says in verse 11 and 12 that they are protected by God the
Father and Jesus, and then it says none of them is lost, in verse 12.
It also says in verse 18 that they are sent like Jesus.
So it is striking then that Jesus takes these people who are
clearly right with God, clearly Christians, and his prayer for them
in John 17:17 is, "Sanctify
them by the truth;
your word is truth." And then he says, "As you have sent me into the world, I have
sent them into the world. And for them, I sanctify
myself that they may be truly sanctified." Now, if you're a Bible
scholar, that's a significant formulation. You remember when we studied Leviticus?
There are definite echoes here of the formulation God the Father uses,
"Be holy for I the Lord your God am holy."
Jesus says, "For their sakes, I sanctify myself that they might be
sanctified." Right? So in John 15:3, Jesus
says to his disciples, "You are clean," catharsis,
and this same Greek word is used in Matthew 5:8, where
he says, "Blessed are the pure in heart," those that have had
catharsis, "for they shall see God." So these men are
clearly headed to see God. They're clean.
They are pure in heart. So what cleaning more do they need?
Now, I want you to remember what happens next after Jesus' prayer. You remember?
The next day,
he dies,
and then he rises and appears to disciples and tells
them to wait because the promise of the Father is
coming. And so they do, and God keeps his promise, and in Acts
2, the Holy Spirit is poured out. So in Acts
2, we have this filling with the Holy Spirit.
And then in Acts 10, there's another group filled with the Spirit, and there
is some controversy there, and Peter's called in to explain.
And so when he does, when Peter explains in Acts 15,
he says that what happened to them is the same thing that happened to us.
It was the cleansing, catharsis, of their heart by
faith. So I want you to notice three things.
One, when we trust in Jesus, something gets cleaned.
Number two, something further gets cleaned when we're filled with the Holy
Spirit. You compare it Acts two and Acts 15.
And number three, this cleansing can be associated with Jesus's
prayer to sanctify his people who were already
clean. Now, so here's today's metaphor.
Holiness is a further cleaning, a cleansing of the
heart that results in a purification after
salvation of those who are initially sanctified.
So I think you and I can say, "Oh Lord,
thank you for the cleaning that you've done in me in salvation.
And now, Lord, I ask that according to your word, you would
clean me further. Whatever that takes and whatever it
looks like, that's what I want from you." And so we can do that today.
We can expect God to give us that further
cleansing that only he can produce in our heart through the power of the
Holy Spirit, the filling of the Holy Spirit in response to Jesus'
prayer that those who are already clean would be further
cleaned. So that's me and you. Let's do it, okay? I'll talk to you tomorrow.